[موسيقى]
ومن طوكيو تنورنا اليوم العزيزه ميسون
اهلا بك منوره اليابان نورتنا
صباح الخير سهام صباح الخير نادين حقيقه
وانا ما تاريخ هذه المدينه بيعود لزمن
بعيد جدا وهي مشهوره
بانها هناك صناعات الصيد البحري والاعشاب
البحريه مدينه كثير حلوه مدينه رايقه كثير
مليئه اكثر شيء بالاوتيلات لانه حكما
كرمال ديزني
جدا هادئه اصلا قريات ومعناها الخليج
الهادئ تاسست سنه عام
1889 على الرغم من انه همم مشيت مع
الحضاره اليابانيه والتطور الحاصل في
اليابان وانما هناك متحف في قرى ياسو ضل
محافظه
[موسيقى]
القديمه اليابان بتخبر عن قصه الصيد
البحري في هذه هي المدينه وتاريخها اذا
بنمشي بهذا المتحف الارض كلها صدف او كل
البيوت الخشبيه اللي بنشوفها دخلها كلها
ادوات خاصه بالصيد وايضا هناك
كانت ايضا
افرجيكم شويه على هذه البيوت الخشبيه ماذا
تحتوي على انواع السمك اللي كانوا
يصطادوها همم وكما ذكرنا هي مدينه جدا جدا
هادئه وحلو كثير همم واحد اذا حابب هيك
يتمتع بالهدوء وبالروق لازم يجيء على قرعه
على كل حال ميسون زميلتنا اشواق راح اسبوع
على كوريا الجنوبيه وصارت تقول انا هلا
مترجمه ودليل سياحي هل انت لمست انه درتي
تاخذي كلمات حسيت انه طوكيو قريبه منا مش
بعيده كل البعد زي ما احنا بنفكر وكانها
كوكب اخر
ليكي صراحه نادين ااه يعني نحنا كملنا
زرنا سول من كم يوم وهلا نحن باليابان
هناك تعلق بلغتهم بشكل كثير كبيره يعني
نحن عم بنعاني
نفهم عليهم ونفهموا علينا مقدمين كل الوقت
انا وزميل باسل وكان زميلنا عقيل وخمسين
معنا مقضيين على الجوجل ترانسليت استغربته
كثير قليل الناس اللي بتعرف انجلش هناك
تمسك بلغتهم بشكل كتير كتير ولكن حاولنا
هيك شويه مثلا صباح العربيه عربيه
مرحبا مرحبا
كم كلمه بس كثير حقيقه صعب ولكن همم
باحبكم طبعا انا بحبكم كثير
وميسون هذول كمان جبت لنا اياهم جوجل
ترانسليت ولا ساعدوك الصبايا كانوا بالاول
لا الصبايا اللي كانوا معنا هيك ساعدونا
وانا حطيتهم كمان على جوجل ترانسليت يعني
حاولت قد ما في احفظهم بس حقيقه تقسما
باللغه ولكن نادين اللي كثير حلو باليابان
ومتحطه بكوريا الجنوبيه هي موضوع النظافه
بشكل يعني ما بتتخيلوا قديش في نظافه
بهالمدينه همم وغير النظافه الناس اللي
فيها شعبه مين ما يشوفك على طول فيها
الانحناء قدمك على طول فيها الاحترام على
طول الابتسامه بس تسالين اي سؤال لو ما
فهموا عليك دغري بيغش من الضحك وبتسموا لك
وهذه الشغله بتعطيكي هيك بوظت فايلز بتحسي
انه الدنيا بالف خير في ناس بعد مبسوطه
كثير بهذه الدنيا واكيد وميسون احنا ما
بدنا نطول عليك بدنا اياك تروحي على ديزني
لاند هلا سريعه طوكيو وكمان بنذكر انه
مباريات كاس العالم
بنشير انه على سيره الشعب الياباني
بالمباراه الاولى كان في فيديوهات لافته
اقتصاد سوشيال ميديا انه عمالهم بينطفوا
الملعب بمبادرات شخصيه منهم وتوزعوا في كل
صحيح